Hello everyone and welcome to a special
Win-Win episode.
An episode where you get to see me cry
over a chicken dumpling.
Because I recently visited Uma Valeti,
the CEO and founder of Upside Foods.
Now Upside are one of a growing number
of companies developing what is known
as cultivated meat.
Meat that is 100 % animal.
But instead of being grown on the
skeleton of an animal in a farm, that
meat is grown in a bioreactor.
Which I appreciate sounds rather sci-fi.
But as someone who is a huge meat
lover, and also a huge animal lover,
this technology is a real win-win in my book.
Because let's face it, the modern meat
industry sucks, especially factory
farms, not only in how they treat their
animals, but also what they're doing to
our environment, and even to our own
health with things like antibiotic resistance.
So for me at least, this technology
provides an elegant solution to the
cognitive dissonance that I often have
around my own carnivorousness.
This episode is a look behind the
scenes of what it's taken to bring this
technology to a point where it is
almost ready for market.
And quick disclaimer, I am an investor
in Upside Foods and wasn't paid or even
asked make this video.
I just really, really believe in this technology.
So I'm happily shilling for it, for
reasons you'll hear.
But please do keep that in mind as you
watch, obviously.
That out of the way, let's dig in.
So Uma, what are we going to be trying today?
We're going to try a number of things
that you can do with chicken.
He's doing dumplings.
He's going to make a breakfast sausage,
complete whole cut chicken breast, that
we do our own version of.
And then we're going to go into fried chicken.
We wanted to pick something very familiar.
Chicken is the most familiar meat.
People love eating chicken in many
forms and we're like, let's not
compromise that experience.
People should recognize that when it
hits their taste buds, oh yeah, I know that.
Yes.
So as you can imagine, I was pretty
excited to try this stuff.
But first, let's hear how Uma went from
being a cardiologist to a cultivated
meat grower.
When I was 12 I went to a friend's
birthday party, our neighbor.
We were in the front of the house
having a lot of fun and then I just
walked to the back of the house and in
the back of the house was where they
were slaughtering the animals to feed
the people in the front.
I think that was the first time ever I
came face to face with the duality of
meat production.
I didn't do anything about it then.
I kept eating meat.
I loved eating meat and then I went
medical school.
So we had this group of 50, 60 kids
that were in one medical school.
I volunteered to run the cafeteria and
during that time I used to go with the
chefs and the sous-chefs to the market
and buy all of the produce and all of
the stuff.
One day we went to actually the meat,
the slaughterhouse and I saw for the
first time intensified, intense animal
production operations chickens.
And that was like a moment I can't forget.
I'm like, on a chain, there were 60
chickens every second being
slaughtered, moved to the next thing,
slaughtered, moved to the next thing.
I did not know how to react.
But I think those two moments, the
birthday, death day when I was 12 years
old, and this was when I was 18 years old.
I'm like, okay, I love eating meat, but
I'm going to stop eating meat.
And that's what, that's the choice I
made for myself.
I didn't tell anyone.
And then I came to the US to do
cardiology at the Mayo Clinic, I was
fortunate to be able to get there.
And as I was training to be a
cardiologist, international
cardiologist, we also started working
on stem cells.
And stem cells are these incredibly
versatile cells in every person's body,
are also animals bodies where these
cells can do anything.
They can become muscle, they can become
connective tissue, they can become
bone, they can become brain cells.
cells, and what we were doing were
taking those cells and injecting them
into patients' hearts when they had a
heart attack or a cardiac arrest.
As I started thinking about it, I'm
like, could we actually do this with
animals and take cells from an animal
and grow meat?
And that was somewhere in the range of,
I think, 2005 or so, that idea came
into my head and I could not get it out.
I just could not get it.
I tried really hard because there was
lots of things going on in cardiology,
but every Every morning I wake up and
that thought comes back to my mind.
So I started talking about that with my
friends, my family, and finally people,
they got fed up with me talking about
it and not doing anything.
And they said, why are you not doing it?
So that became a call to action.
But how does it work?
Like how can you begin to grow meat
without its host animal?
So the process starts with us taking
cells from either an adult animal,
young animal, or an egg.
It's a small biopsy, and a biopsy
usually gets you one or two drops worth
of cells from any part of the animal.
And once we do that, we take those
cells and we grow them outside the
animal with nutrients and identify the
animal cells that do a fantastic job of
growing and retaining the flavor and
the textures.
They are the ones that graduate to
become a commercial breed at Upside.
Once they do that, we don't have to go
back to the animal.
So for instance, these chickens
products you're eating today, we got
them from the source about four or five
years ago from a chicken, and we
haven't had to go back.
We can keep producing with that for the
next 30 years.
The DNA is identical to the sort of old
school style of chicken.
Yeah, I mean, the DNA here is chicken DNA.
Like, if you just go and do, put it
through any DNA reading and ask it to
read what species is this, it'll say
gallus gallus.
So the DNA question is probably the
biggest misunderstanding I keep hearing
about cultivated meat.
People understandably assume that it
must be genetically modified in some
way in order to grow.
But it's not.
It's genetically identical to whatever
farmed animal the cell samples
originally come from.
So it's not a GMO food.
What is different though is how much
time and energy and space it takes to
grow the meat, especially when you
compare it pound for pound to current methods.
Any meat takes about two weeks, maybe
it takes three weeks, maybe it takes
four weeks if you're trying to add some
exquisite features into it.
But let's say it averages out at two
weeks or let's push it to three weeks.
When you compare that with a cow, which
is two years, a pig, which is nine
months, and and the chicken, which is
two months.
And the lamb is about six months.
It's just a much shorter process, 4X to
almost 50X.
And in terms of energy efficiency,
again, I don't know if you can make a
comparison, but how much energy it
takes to get a kilogram of steak versus
a kilogram of steak grown in a lab, how
much more energy is that?
Yes.
So we have our own work that we've done
and started to say, at scale, when we
project out our production methods, the
efficiency and the time it takes for us
to grow the meat and compare with the
literature out there, the majority of
it is saying unequivocally that when we
get to scale of tens of millions of
pounds or hundreds of millions of
pounds, the land use goes down to about
90 % less than what we need for
conventional meat.
meat, the water use goes down by about
90 plus percent to what it requires to
feed an animal before it's slaughtered.
And the greenhouse gas emissions also
go down by about 90 percent.
So those three things, greenhouse gas
emissions, land use, water use, go down
about 90 percent.
We have 70 billion animals right now
drinking a third of all the fresh water
that we have in the world, using a
third of all the arable land to make
the feed for them.
and if the demand for meat is doubling,
simple math.
That means animals will be drinking
two-thirds of all the fresh water 30
years from now that's on Earth, and
two-thirds of all the agricultural land
is going to be used to grow crops for
feeding animals to feed humans.
That math won't work out.
And the thing is, he is right.
As more and more poor countries
modernize, trends show that their
demand for meat will significantly
increase, which is going to make our
current, very inefficient farming
system even more unsustainable long-term.
A statistic that really blows my mind
is just how much the distribution of
biology on Earth has changed since the
agricultural revolution.
Before humans started farming, we only
made up a tiny sliver of all the
biomass on Earth.
Now we and our livestock represent 98 %
of all biomass.
That's more than a 10,000x increase,
much of which has only happened in the
last couple hundred years.
So such a rapid swing is obviously
going to create a huge shock on any
ecosystem, but ultimately I can throw
stats around all day long and none of
this matters if this meat doesn't
actually taste good, or at least taste
as good as what you can buy in a supermarket.
So here is my rather emotional taste test.
Does the product feel different in any
way to cook with?
No, we've kind of put it through its
paces, you know, we've kind of tried
all sorts of stuff.
We've fried it, we've brined it, we've
smoked it, we've made sausages, we've
made kind of everything that you could
kind of imagine.
And yeah, it really acts in the same
way as you would expect chicken.
So this is the potsticker, so like Uma
said, this is cultivated chicken.
It has some ginger, scallion, kind of
traditional seasonings in there.
Have you ever tasted cultivated meat,
by the way?
I have never tasted cultivated meat before.
I have been waiting years to do this.
As someone who like I love meats but I
love animals and I love earth this is
like this is the ultimate win-win
technology I'm quite actually
emotionally well we're exactly the same
it's so good it's I mean it's it's I
don't think I would there's no way I
could tell the difference that's
amazing thank you for saying that this
is the reaction we get every single
time people come in and taste it.
It just feels really good.
Wow.
We have a lot more products.
I'm so impressed.
Has anyone ever cried before when
they've eaten it?
A few have.
A few have?
Okay, good.
So I'm not the only winner.
It's actually, I can't believe it's real.
I can't believe it's real.
So yes, I can definitively say it
passed the taste test, at least to me.
But of course, the question you're
probably all wondering is, what are the
health and safety the implications of
this technology.
I mean, after all, we've evolved to eat
meat conventionally for thousands of years.
And this is as far away from nature as
you can get, really.
So how can these companies ensure that
it lives up to safety and nutritional standards?
Presumably, you don't actually have
any, you can't have any long-term
studies, right, on the effect of humans
eating cultivated meat because it's so new.
You know, the first person ate, what,
in 2013?
Mark Post Burger, in 2013 August, about
10 years ago, is the first time that
was eaten publicly, televised.
But there have been people who have
been tasting it before that, and at
various small events.
But you're right, it all has been
happening in the last 10-15 years.
Are there any studies planned to sort
of measure the effects on people who
have been eating it consistently and so on?
because I imagine there's going to be a
lot of people who, you know, aren't
willing to try it until there is some
sort of long-term study.
I think there will be.
You know, I get calls from people that
are very interested in doing studies
and people that have scientifically
rigorous things that want to do
long-term studies.
And I said, those should happen.
They will happen as they should happen
in a very well-designed fashion.
It'll take time to make all of these
studies happen, but it'll come back to
the challenge, which is, what do you
compare it with?
Where is the gold standard?
What do you accept?
If you accept a third of us could
develop cancers from the food that we
eat, we're already at that level right now.
So in scientific design of a proper
study that can be interpreted well, we
really have to keep those things in
mind and start questioning that because
that's also changed over time.
There's so many of these caveats that
we need to think about designing studies.
And what I would say is, let's step back.
Let's step back and say, are there any
studies that just say, I'm going to put
people in eating conventional meat-only
category and people that don't eat any
meat at all in their diet category?
Do we actually have really strong
evidence to say one group is at a
higher risk than the other group?
Now, if that study has not been done,
then in that case, if you do a
meta-study on top of it without a
proper foundation, it becomes very
challenging to interpret.
So the way we approach it is the following.
We're like, let's make sure that we
know everything possible about the
cell, we know everything possible about
the nutrition that is going into these
cells, and we know the growing
conditions, and everything that we do
is trackable.
How can you ensure that the meat
products are as healthy for you as, you
know, say a chicken breast I would go
buy, you know, from a conventional farm?
Or, you know, perhaps more accurately,
let's compare it to like a factory farm.
We can compare to free range as well,
but maybe in a more factory farms,
which is where, you know, 90 % of meat
is coming from nowadays, right?
So we think about putting products that
are nutritionally rich and part of a
well-balanced diet.
Conventional meat, as we know it, and
processed meats, as we know it, have
been associated with certain diseases,
whether it's cardiovascular disease or
cancers or chronic diseases or diseases
that could lead to inflammation.
Now, when I step back as a physician
and think about what are we trying to
really do here, I think the opportunity
with cultivated meat to start making
meat better is significantly higher
than you can ever imagine with
conventional meat.
And a couple of examples.
If we know how to select cells that are
capable of giving us the right omega-3,
omega-6 ratios, Suddenly it's like,
okay, can I make beef with the health
benefits for the heart, like a salmon?
Those possibilities open up.
And that's when my eyes light up, our
team's eyes light up, and say, yes, we
see that.
We can start thinking about touching
that future.
Do you need to use, because I know in
conventional farming, and especially in
factory farms, the amount of antibiotic
usage is, I couldn't find the exact
numbers on what percentage of
antibiotics worldwide are actually
given to farm animals, but it's a very
significant amount, which is obviously
contributing to antibiotic resistance,
other sort of growing threats.
And people are quite understandably
concerned about the idea that they're
ingesting meat from animals that have
been consuming so many antibiotics.
Do you have to use them in your systems?
Answer is no.
All the products you eat, they never
say antibiotics.
And that's what's going to be another
distinct advantage cultivated meat, right?
As we start scaling our production
techniques and keep going to scale,
people are going to see that.
And 60 to 80 % of all the antibiotics
made in the United States are made for
animals, not for humans.
That's a very large percentage.
So what's happening to all of that antibiotics?
The animal is eating and then it's
secreting it or excreting it, and it
gets into the runoff, and then we get
exposed to that.
And there's a lot of worry about
antibiotic resistance.
And we've seen lots of antibiotic
resistance organisms with hundreds of
thousands of people being affected
every year and tens of thousands dying
from it.
So that's one distinct advantage.
The second one is pandemic risk.
I worry about that even more because
antibiotic resistance, major problem,
can affect pockets of people and it
could be a It's a slow-rolling disaster.
When you suddenly think about
pandemics, the biggest risk that we are
facing and looking at every day in the
eye is, if you are confining 70 billion
animals every year in tiny, tiny areas,
and those animals are so close to each
other, in the middle of breeding,
infectious agents circulating, and
excreting their excrement all being in
one place.
It's like a Petri dish.
It's the literal petri dish.
Talk about an entire lab-grown
experiment in the world that we do
every single second on a massive,
massive scale.
That is the lab-grown experiment that
I'm very scared of.
We've lived that through the pandemic,
of what it can cause to our lives and
do to our lives.
I lost my dad from COVID, and he's a veterinarian.
He and we used to talk about this
pandemic risk, always, zoonotic
diseases spreading from an animal,
either a wild animal or a domesticated
animal jumping into humans, always
talked about it.
It just is really sad that I lost my
dad to it.
But when these things start happening
to people, we've got to be able to say,
let's open our eyes wide.
Let's look at opportunities where we
can decrease that risk.
I'd love to get into the sort of more
economic side of it.
Yes, let's do it.
So, initially, the production of, I
think, a pound of beef through
cultivated meat was $18,000 a pound.
Chicken was $9,000 a pound.
Where is the price down to
approximately now?
And how do you plan to scale it so that
it becomes commercially competitive to
conventional meat?
This is a fantastic question.
It comes every single day for us.
And our answer is there's three things
we are focusing on.
People have to fall in love with the product.
People have to be able to afford it.
And then people have to be able to see
how it's made.
Those are a must-have.
How do we take care of the first taste thing?
That's the first magical thing for
people to see.
They have to come into a kitchen, see
it being cooked, and taste, right?
We're never going to pass the sniff
test if we don't get across that.
So that was the laser focus for the
last, for the first three, four years.
The focus now is cost.
We're like, we want to be able to put
this product on the market.
It's going to be expensive to make it
in the early days, but we do want to be
able to price it for a consumer in the
range of a premium meat product that
they're going to be able to go and buy
at a restaurant.
If they're buying a chicken sandwich,
if they're paying $15 for a chicken
sandwich now, they're like, we want to
be able to capture a slight premium on
that because it helps us continue to do
the research and innovation.
So what we're thinking is price it
above organic in the range of 30 % or so
above organic.
That we think a lot of people can start
affording to pay right now, enough for
us to be able to keep building the
business and start saying, we'll get
closer and closer to conventional meat
price parity, which will be another 50 %
lower than what an organic chicken
costs right now.
Those are what our North Stars are, and
our first products that we'll put on
the market will be in that range.
The cost of manufacturing it is higher
right now because we're doing it in
small-scale, a lot more bespoke craft
type of manufacturing, but when we are
building the next commercial facility
based on what we are sitting in right now.
That is focused on bringing the cost of
chicken to $10 a pound.
That's the goal we've got.
The next one is to get it to $5 a pound.
I think that is kind of where it's
going if we use today's prices.
What about the role of subsidies?
Because I think what a lot of people
don't realize is, you know, a lot of
the meat and food that we eat is
already very subsidized, right?
Is that the case with meat?
And do you think it could be the case
with cultivated meat too?
The conventional industry has taken
advantage of enormous amounts of
subsidies, incentives, loan programs,
tax benefits to get to a place of
efficiency that they're at right now.
Right.
That took several decades for them to
get there.
And there has been an incredible amount
of taxpayer support private, and
public-private partnerships.
And I think if we have to be realistic
and say a transformative change like
this should be funded similar to that,
that's a level playing field.
And we will have to be eligible for all
of these same benefits that
conventional meat industry has been
able to avail for cultivated meat to go
to the next level.
And there's great examples of that that
we've been living through.
Think about the energy transformation
happening right now.
The Infrastructure Act, the CHIPS Act,
the IRA, all of these are offering an
ability for American manufacturing to
be able to compete with Chinese
manufacturing or some other
manufacturing location.
So on that note, let's finish up with
the main course of the day, a full
cultivated chicken breast fillet.
Unlike ground chicken, a full fillet
like you'd get straight off the breast
of a living chicken is, of course, much
harder to produce, given all the sinew
and nerves and stuff that normally hold
a breast muscle together.
But they've even cracked that, too.
So this is the high water mark for our company.
This is the same product that's going
to Dominique Ren.
So it looks exactly how this looks, is
what we're sending to her, and it's all
made here in the facility.
So this is over 99 % cultivated meat.
Yeah, so this is made with a different
process than the previous deep products.
So in this method of production for the
chicken breast, what we have is we have
the cells together and we keep them
close enough that they actually start
attaching to each other physically and
they start forming the junctions and
attach and then they line up in a file
and that's what you need for a fiber
and then they are stacked up against
each other and then they start becoming
more and more fibers and then the cells
themselves secrete something called the
extracellular matrix basically
collagens and elastins that hold them
together so therefore when you pull out
the chunk of meat it's all staying
together excuse my feralness but i want
to i want to experience the actual
texture so let's see up close just
straight up to your breast that is just
what This is a world we should live in,
where we can have all the protein that
we need and want without the endless
suffering and environmental degradation
that comes with it.
There we go, thank you so much for
watching everyone, and of course a huge
thank you to Uma and his team at Upside
for letting me come ask them questions,
for letting me grill them.
There you go, there's the pun of the day.
Anyway, if you found this interesting
or useful, please share.
I'm also really curious to know if
you'd actually try this meat if it was
given to you, you know, offered on a plate.
Let me know what you think in the comments.
But either way, I'm really hopeful that
this meat will become an option for
those who would like to try it soon.
Because as I said, I think it's a
massive win-win.
It's a win-win-win-win.
Animals, environment, people's health,
sustainability, doesn't mean you can't
eat conventional meat anymore.
That will still be there.
It's all about choice maximization.
So anyway, on that note, thank you and
I'll see you next time.